[Music]
this is how enterprise teams can succeed
using firebase and for those of you who
don't know who I am which is probably
like one or two of you max my name
Haskins
I say I'm a software engineer but I'm
actually not allocating developer
relations at Google working on firebase
I've been working on firebase in one way
or the other for about six years which
is about six of the seven years firebase
has existed as a product so I have been
helping people big companies small
companies hobbyist kids in school etc
etcetera use firebase for a long time
and this is gonna be the trend in this
talk is that I do not care I genuinely
do not care if you go and leave today
and think I need to use firebase for
something it's gonna make me super
successful like that's great if you do
leave with that but I have no interest
at all in you going and using firebase
only to figure out that it doesn't work
well with your product it's not a good
investment like you you misplaced
engineering time or anything like that
my goal here is to help you be informed
and if firebase is the right thing for
you I'd love for you to go use it but
I've been doing this long enough that I
know telling you anything but the
absolute truth is not gonna do you any
good so that's what I'm gonna do I I'm
honest when I say I have no interest in
selling you anything I just hope you can
leave today with a little more
information about firebase and a little
bit of a better idea about what it takes
to run fireplace in a big team with a
big product and to succeed doing that I
think the thing that is the core of all
of this when you're building anything
large is you got to be confident all
right you have to be confident in a
bunch of factors and if you're a small
company you have to be confident in
things like being able to pay the rent
next month but as you grow and you get
revenue and things like this your
concerns change and you have to be
focused about scaling confident about
scaling the team or you need to be
confident about being able to roll back
something when it gets pushed into
production and it has some issue
but the general theme building
confidently always applies it doesn't
matter who you are in my experience the
idea of building confidently kind of
breaks down into a few core components
and these are what we're gonna be
talking about today and specifically
talking about how to how to use these
things as we scale up as we you know
deploying the bigger teams and we get
past that like small company building on
firebase kind of thing so those topics
are how to build clean and strong code a
lot of these topics will be engineering
related but not specifically about
writing code they're more about managing
code managing projects how to deal with
teams and adding developers and things
like that then we'll be dealing with the
idea of systematic testing and again you
might think all right testing we have
Quality Assurance people we have our
developers write tests but this is more
about like as an organization as a team
as several teams working on micro
services or whatever what do we do to
ensure that testing is consistent
systematic and as useful as it can be
without putting too much burden on
anyone then we're going to talk about
dealing with instant deployments and
rollback how we can react to things when
inevitably our tests don't catch
something we push something bad into
production we won't dive too deep into
that it'll just kind of be a high level
overview but it's still a really useful
topic after that we'll talk about
something that a lot of enterprises care
about with firebase which is dealing
with multiple environments we want to
have staging environments and production
environments we want to have different
services that our products connect to
depending on what environment they're in
we want this or that and we'll talk
about how that works in a firebase world
then we'll talk about monitoring and
kind of dive into how do we get
confidence in what's happening in our
application
anytime you trust a cloud provider as
you know like right there that word
trust comes up you have to have
confident that we are doing the right
thing on your behalf and so we'll talk
about how you can keep an eye on us
ensure that what we're doing on your
behalf is what you want this is things
like uptime and on-call rotations and
ideas like that
then after that we'll talk a bit about
pricing I'm far from I price
guru but I can give you some hints about
how to think about pricing as it relates
to firebase how to do some sort of
forward-looking analysis just a little
bit on that and just some of the value
props that change when you're looking at
using something like firebase versus a
more closer to bare metal stack like
Google cloud or even a fully traditional
in your on-premise solution so that's
what we're gonna go over we're going to
just step through those one at a time so
we're just gonna dive into the first one
which is clean strong code now if you
are existing company using firebase
there's a couple of situations you might
find yourself in in generally enterprise
developers find themselves in one
specific one which is that you have some
product and that product makes a lot of
money for your company probably
hopefully and you have some other part
that is the part that uses firebase this
happens for a lot of reasons but the
biggest ones are that firebase is a
great value add so if you're a new team
building up something inside of a bigger
company it lets you move fast it lets
you do things really quickly you can
kind of get like a minimum viable thing
out and then iterate on it and we see a
lot of products like that using firebase
and then the other type of enterprise
using firebase is any enterprise that's
actually relying on firebase as its core
a core part of its business this is
extremely rare and this is one of the
reasons that it's important firebase is
as connected is to Google cloud as it is
today we want to make sure that as you
grow and build with firebase there's a
clear connection between firebase and
Google cloud so if you're using Google
cloud or you're using firebase and your
feet realize you need something from the
other one they're not mutually exclusive
they're designed to work together and
you know kind of help each other but in
either of these cases if you're using
firebase somewhere in your stack you've
probably realized that the code you're
writing is a little sloppy this happens
all the time it's just kind of part of
building things today and I would argue
that it's not just a side effect of
writing code I think there's a specific
culture that working with firebase lends
itself to which is that culture building
quickly and iterating on things that
also lends itself to writing bad code
and that that's what I call the MVP
culture
that Minimum Viable Product culture and
this is a bit of a tangent I'll give you
that but I think it's a really
interesting one to think about where if
you're building an MVP inside of your
enterprise which is as I said what a lot
of firebase developers do then you have
to wonder what is changing about this
product as I'm building it right like
you're like okay these features are
gonna change I'm gonna figure out what
users want and respond to that but in
that in that churn what happens to the
code right the code gets mangled they're
like oh there's this whole other thing
we built we don't need and then we drop
that off we don't do anything with it
we built up this other part maybe the
entire original purpose of the codebase
gets shifted all sorts of crazy things
happen and that's fine because when
we're building an MVP were writing the
minimum amount of code we're doing so in
a way that allows us to because the
iteration time is faster we're not
spending a ton of time like declaring a
soap API or something crazy like that
we're just like it throw up some
JavaScript they're upset a server list
function that can do this and and if
there's a mouse pretend that didn't
happen you know and all of these things
are are fine but the result in this the
end result is not just a better product
at the end of the day but it's actually
pretty expensive because you're
iterating on this codebase very quickly
you're changing things and as you do
that you're gonna allow your developers
more time to go back and rewrite the
same thing and rewrite this ending and
you build up a lot of code debt this way
you build up a lot of issues that you're
gonna have to deal with down the road
and this is part of this MVP culture
that people don't really talk about and
I see this particularly in enterprises
trying to spin up things quickly in
firebase because they're always under
crazy constraints and you're always have
something that has to be done next week
and they they build like this so when we
talk about MVPs when we talk about this
idea of iterating quickly there is there
is one friendly language that always
comes up this is this one is JavaScript
if you have ever written anything with
firebase you probably touch JavaScript
at some point whether it's using one of
our JavaScript SDKs or using the cloud
functions which most people write in
JavaScript but
despite the better iteration time
despite JavaScript's ability to allow
you to write code really fast and spend
stuff up and you know really quickly get
something together it has a ton of
downsides and some of you may be
thinking of course I know JavaScript is
not the perfect language but I really
want to stress this as it relates to
firebase because a huge number of
developers don't understand that if
you're using something like cloud
functions for firebase or any of our
other services you are definitely not
locked into javascript javascript makes
sense in some situations but in others
it doesn't and so here's an example a
snippet of JavaScript this is a some
code that interacts with firebase it's
just like a call to the database checks
if a user has an admin role returns the
value and if you were a really keen
JavaScript developer or even like a
pretty keen JavaScript developer you
might realize that this sniff it makes
no sense alright but if you were
anything but a pretty keen JavaScript
developer this probably looked fine and
this is exactly the issue with
JavaScript as it grows and as you work
with bigger teams and grow your product
and things like that a big developer a
real good developer can see the problem
here but an average developer can't a
new developer can't a developer who's
not familiar with firebase or these SDKs
can't all right so here's the tree treat
of what's wrong with this obviously
firebase database is a function so
you're missing your invocation there you
know how could you not notice that we're
missing a return this value never
actually gets out anywhere we don't have
a callback we don't return the promise
and of course that string bail is
actually supposed to be value all these
are trivial right there are a couple
characters they're an easy mistake to
make even if you're familiar with
javascript with the firebase SDK but if
you are not that person if you were
anyone else coming into this team you're
probably gonna miss this so this leads
me to a general idea I have about
choosing languages and choosing what to
build your product and what to build
with in firebase which is that the
language your code is in should be as
strict as the contracts provided by the
services it interacts with this is kind
of a weird mantra
and it basically is saying don't use
JavaScript it's probably the wrong idea
it's it's a little more formal than that
so you can tell it to people and they
think you're smart but let me explain
what I mean here so imagine you have a
big micro service architecture maybe
it's a service architecture you got a
bunch of functions around that's great
right you have some off service that a
bunch of other services rely on you have
ordering and scheduling and tracking and
reporting and that core service provides
an API that all of these services relate
to in reality there's a chance at first
that the ordering and the scheduling and
the tracking and the reporting and the
author all maintained by the same team
but once you grow once you get a few
auth providers once you get a bigger and
bigger team you're going to get a bunch
of these that are all now providing
different api's that all of these
services are now expected to know how to
interact with and this this interaction
here that Jason bit is a very loose very
very soft format you can send back
anything you want and the other service
is expected to handle it
so if for example our social author
Facebook authen or Twitter auth hands
back an object to these services that
looks one way maybe it has display
underscore name but our internal off
that hands back something else that
hands back something that's called
display name with a capital N
you know camelcase so we get into this
issue right where now these core
services are providing different api's
different services to all these
dependents and now each of these
dependents is responsible for handling
the different cases of different
situations that could be provided by
this very loose API and in this case
JavaScript might make sense because if
all of these services are providing
different things you don't have a strong
contract between your different services
between your service functions and your
client-side if you don't have that
guarantee you want a very flexible
language you want a language like
JavaScript that can take whatever you
give it and probably mangle it into
something usable but we don't want to
get in this situation in the first place
because this doesn't scale right like as
soon as you start doing this a bunch and
you have not only an auth service or a
few officers
maintained perhaps by different people
at least some were maintained by people
from three years ago some are working
there now some don't know you're gonna
hit this issue so we have this snippet
with a bunch issues right and of course
we're thinking well we aren't talking
about Jason here when we're not talking
about any interaction here that is nice
and soft and loose like Jason we have a
really strong contract here we have an
SDK we have a nice nice documented clean
consistent properly typed beautiful SDK
firebase SDK here and we're just
throwing that all the way and we're just
like we don't care that this does not
you know this may have might be able to
tell me that database is a function we
don't care that it knows it's supposed
to take value we just toss this out and
this is kind of the core realization
here that I'd like you to take away from
this bit which is that like the dusty
case that we provide that Google Cloud
provides a fibrous provides these are
contracts that we are making to you
obviously not legal contracts not
something that you know you can sue us
if we change but they are the type of
thing that we do our absolute best not
to mess with you and not to change so in
this situation where we have all of this
information throwing it away using it in
JavaScript makes a lot less sense so
this SDK is a strong contract right
we're communicating between these
services in this case firebase services
but in this in this example it's a
internal app communicating to a
dependent strongly typed languages make
more sense because there is nothing
loose here there's nothing flexible
about this contract from another service
so if we look at the snippet again we
think all right why are we relying on a
language that lets us have that
flexibility it really doesn't gain us
that much in fact it makes the situation
worse because now developers are making
mistakes they have to iterate more they
have to come back and as things change
which they inevitably will they are more
likely to break this code so here's
here's the same function rewritten into
a typed language
it looks almost identical doesn't it
yeah I mean yeah it's it's pretty much
it's it's slightly different it honestly
just looks like more modern JavaScript
but introducing some typescript into the
situation changes the world for us this
is now a valid typescript snippet and
although we haven't put any types on
here we don't say you ideas the string
we don't you know promise that we're
going to return a value or anything like
that we are making use of the contract
provided by firebase because if we try
to compile this and turn it into
JavaScript and we have any of those
mistakes back here give me if we had any
other mistakes back here typescript
would tell us right so we're making a
very small change like a few characters
but now the end result is that our code
is making use of that contract it's
saying I know you're giving me this
study you're giving me these fields and
these objects and these things like that
let's actually listen and and obey those
so just the switch to typescript very
low cost in general especially for new
projects if you're building something up
old and you're trying to transition it
it can be pretty expensive to shift but
if you're building something new you're
trying to MVP something this will save
you time just switching the typescript
I love typescript but my whole talk is
not just about touch good but one last
part that is about typescript is code
completion I don't know if you've ever
used JavaScript code completion or if
you've ever seen a new developer on your
team try to figure out what the hell is
going on
in your JavaScript but they're not gonna
get anything that's pretty they're not
gonna get anything that says here are
the methods that are actually on this
SDK they're gonna get a whole bunch of
junk that like sublime thinks it can
really read and realize because it's got
some crazy reg X and it's like this is
probably a JavaScript value but it's not
good it's not helpful and frankly it can
be misleading so if we use a stronger
typed language not only have we now
enabled our systems to you know use and
consume those contracts but we're not
yeah we're not we're improving the
experience for these new developers
they're coming in and they're seeing
this and they're saying all right I can
figure this out I can reason about this
better I can get up to speed quicker and
I can make changes more confidently so
one last bit about this whole service
contract language decision
I want to point out that services or
anything a team relies on which isn't
written by that same team all right so
when I say services I don't just mean
things like Google cloud I don't mean
things like firebase it can be like the
earlier example your auth service
there's no reason your auth service
couldn't provide an SDK with that really
nice strict contract but they maintain
and they give to the other teams and say
you don't have to talk over our JSON API
that API changes will take care of it
but we maintain both the core service
and the Associated SDK which is what you
actually use to talk to our service and
now if they make a change in their SDK
because they made a change on their
server code you can now respond to that
reasonably you can get build time errors
you can get more information then you
would if the if that SDK or that
situation was more loosely typed the
other thing that counts as a service is
every single one of those node modules
you've ever pulled in for example if I
went and I tried to find like a colors
module to just like throw some color in
my logging output I don't know if you
know this but there's 3,600 color
modules which is ridiculous a lot of
them are not what I want
but if I did know what I wanted to be
able to you know kind of reduce it down
to to these two and when I go and I take
on a dependency from a third-party like
this I'm making an agreement with that
person that's saying I'm trusting you
I'm like a bunch of levels I'm trusting
you not to do anything evil in my code
because once I'm importing your
JavaScript you can do whatever the heck
you want you can you know break my page
you can steal my information so you have
like that level of contract and
agreement with them but you're also
making a technical agreement saying
please don't change this API too much
because if you do I'm just I'm not gonna
know like it's just gonna break in
production at some point if they change
others ap has work and some developers
are much more reasonable I'm much more
considerate and they're willing to make
a guarantee of some form with you that
their API is going to be a certain way
and we can look at these two packages if
we were if we were to look at these
without being a JavaScript developer
being a new JavaScript developer or what
have you it would be impossible to tell
which of these is is the ideal one to
use you might know offhand but we can go
and we can look into these repos and we
can check out the the PAC
Jason file four colors and you'll notice
through all this
there's no mentions of types or any
guarantee that what we're outputting
here is going to stay the same and this
is this is the non type script library
it's you know usable but it's also def
deprecated it's several years old and
it's definitely not the choice you want
to make this one chalk on the other hand
you can see right there under files is a
type slash index DTS and that's saying
hey here's the actual file that defines
the contract I'm providing you what your
service can rely on so if this changes
if that DTS file changes on a new
release that'll be a build timer instead
of a runtime error and that's a better
sign of a developer willing to make a
commitment to you making
you know upholding some bar of quality
than the ones who don't so this is a
j-type script kind of situation and I
generally recommend even if you're not
using typescript look for libraries that
support typescript because it's a better
indicator that people are willing to be
consistent and they're not just changing
things willy-nilly under you this
doesn't help at all if this person is
malicious obviously they can still steal
all your information but at least your
codes not going to change so with all
these these thousands of trust
relationships we have right with
external people ideally they would all
be contracts right like every single one
of these we would say you were providing
me this type of SDK you were providing
me this cloud service this whatever
whatever and you would have liked this
very very nice clean structure but there
are certain languages which just don't
lend themselves well to doing this
javascript is one of those so if the
language is weak because that's the
contract between the provider and the
dependent your entire service is going
to be weak if your language is strong
it's gonna be stronger so any you know
strictly typed language go
for example Java for example are great
choices here and luckily you might be
thinking well this is all great but
firebase cloud functions they only
support Java Script
maybe they support typescript but it's
not really there which is not true you
can write go code deploy it up to cloud
functions today you can use all the same
triggers you use you can use all the
same stuff and it's gonna work just as
well we have go SDKs
we have SDKs for many strictly typed
languages on the backend we have a lot
of choices here that aren't JavaScript
that still allow you flexibility and
speed of development but with nice
strict contracts that we are agreeing to
to make sure that what we give you is
either going to be the same as it was
before or it's gonna fail at Build time
so that's my whole spiel about languages
don't write in JavaScript write in
typescript or even better yet write and
go or something like that but we got a
lot off to cover and that was a pretty
long section so I want to talk about
systematic testing so the first thing
about testing if you're writing a big
team and this goes back to that MVP
culture thing right like MVPs generally
don't have tests which is which is
terrible but one of the reasons they
don't is because like testing is pretty
hard it's it's a very difficult thing to
get right and if you're trying to move
quickly a lot of times like move fast
and break things means break things
because we didn't write tests and we
need to do what we can culturally when
we're building things to avoid getting
into situations where it's hard to test
things so here's an example another
snippet another firebase code more
JavaScript and it's unlike the other
JavaScript a little more recent it's got
some async/await got some other stuff
the problem with this code is that the
only thing this javascript module is
exporting is this cloud function
definition so we can deploy this to
firebase and once it's in production of
firebase we can hit it and see what
happens and we can test it but that is
incredibly slow it's like a minute at
least of loop for you to go I'm gonna
change this deploy it test it and worse
than that you need to be deploying it
constantly to our staging environment
which you have to have in the first
place and it's very very tedious so if
we get into a situation where instead of
building out this big method that you
know whatever it does it sends messages
or push notifications to people we
restructure it alright and we expose
that same business logic in multiple
ways that is now independent of the
vendor so this is code and this is an
example of me saying don't do it the
firebase way if you can because all the
testing tools all the unit tools all the
spies and everything like that in the
world
are not going to make it easier for you
to test your code then if you just
exported or Mille method that you can
just tie into and check the result of so
that's what we're doing here we're
taking this old big blob of code and
moving all this business logic all the
part that you'd actually want to test
throwing it into a new method which we
call syndrome and then after that
instead of just exposing that one cloud
function that one firestore trigger
we're going to expose a couple different
things we're gonna expose a manual
trigger which is an HTTP function this
we can emulate locally so it's very easy
to hit and get a response from and see
if Center room with data is working as
we'd expect we we now have the automatic
room which is an automatic sender and
function this is exactly like it was
before and you can see any logic that's
related to that fire store trigger it's
going to be tied in in this little bit
of code so we're pulling in from text
room ID and passing that to send a room
which is just a normal JavaScript
function
so just by reorganizing things a little
bit and you know always having a manual
way to trigger things we're helping
avoid the situation where a developer is
going to go and have to deploy something
to test it and you know reduce that or
increase that time to loop here's
everything we did that makes this better
we export a top-level namespace now
which you can do with Cod functions you
can import like an infinitely deep
object and it'll automatically namespace
things for you so when you deploy this
you'll get FCM underscore manual you'll
get FCM underscore automatic underscore
- into room so we do that we have that
HTTP function we have function specific
logic handled all in the actual trigger
invocation and the business logic pop
somewhere else now this is great this is
a helpful way to like organize your code
but it's not as good as just being able
to invoke this code like as it is like
the full production code naturally which
I have some good news for you I wish I
could tell you more but we are working
on new firebase emulators we're working
on an entire suite of new emulators that
will allow you to do entirely off the
offline development without deploying to
firebase at all so this will make a lot
of things moot in this talk actually but
we're not we're not there yet but once
we're getting there
we're gonna have a much much better
story for you in terms of
and things like that so in the meantime
keep it listening to what I'm saying but
keep a lookout for the new emulators
that are coming down the pipe it's been
far too long that we have not had a good
and offline story for firebase and that
is coming beyond that testing can't be
optional if anything is remotely
difficult and you give someone the
option not to do it they probably won't
do it so we got to make sure they test
their code we can kind of make sure they
write tests right like we can have code
reviews and we can have things like that
that ensure coverage we can use tools
like coveralls to make sure that a good
percentage of our code is covered by
tests but we also have all these tools
this text is a little small but we have
a lot of ways to automatically deal with
running tests that enforce developers
use tests all the time
for example just to name a few you can
use git commit talks so if somebody
commits code it has to pass tests or it
has to have a certain coveralls
percentage we can do automated branch
reviews from bots and things like github
there's hot reloadable tests which make
it much more approachable to rerun tests
we have all sorts of different things
team provided mocks this goes back to
the idea that if your service is
providing an SDK that SDK should also
have mocks provided by that same team we
can have code hygiene practices see ICD
stuff we can have hooks in the firebase
CLI all sorts of stuff that enforce
these tests be ran by our developers so
regardless of who this developer is
they're not getting code in unless I run
the tests and this is all just making it
part of the workflow right we just want
developers to always be thinking I'm
going to write tests for this tests are
my default way of testing this I'm not
gonna click through and click the
buttons and see if it works I'm gonna
write a test because that's gonna be
better I want to talk specifically a bit
more about this which is leading into
our next section about deployments and
rollbacks
some of you've probably heard about this
really cool service we have called cloud
build and if you haven't heard about
cloud build you've probably heard about
one of our competitors products there's
tons of good CI CD options out here and
this is one of those situations where I
don't particularly care if you use cloud
build or use any of the other ones using
one that's best for you
cloud build is sweet because it
integrates with gold clouds or if your
codes already in Google cloud and your
life is already in Google cloud you
might as well use cloud
but there's a lot of great options out
there not a good documentation etc etc
to give you some idea about what
cloudbuilt offers in the simplest
situation if you've never used the ICD
your team is still either manually
moving files to a server or your team is
relying on the one dude who remembers
how to deploy code like he's the one
with the right shell scripts this is for
you if your team already has CI CD stuff
that's fine you can turn out for a
second so cloud build is super
approachable
continuous integration continuous
deployment tool if you don't know what
that means that means when you commit to
get or you hit some button it builds
your code it tests your code and it
ships your code either to production and
staging what-have-you it's a bit hard to
see in this tiny screenshot but the
general idea here is that every time
I've done anything to this codebase it
runs these tests you see a bunch of them
are failing because I wrote a bunch of
bad tests but that's fine it's only
trying to go to product or to staging
it's only going to production it's only
going to staging so if the bill fails it
doesn't matter if it succeeds great I
can go check it and this is kind of the
magic here is that all of the process
that you would normally do to get
something into any environment is
contained here and it's replicatable
because all you have to do is commit to
get or do whatever and that's a very
easy way to get something out the actual
setup for this is like super trivial
again this is probably a bit hard to
read sadly but you just make one of
these wonderful cloud build the mo files
they can pull in any arbitrary docker
file and that can run so we have G cloud
CLI docker files we have firebase CLI
docker files we have all sorts of node
and you know any any static site builder
you would want or anything like that you
can just pull in as I step in this and
then it'll go and every time you commit
it will go and run this and deploy it up
so here's an example of a situation
where I've you know synced it to get you
give a bunch options here you can use
the cloud source repositories which are
the git repos inside of Google cloud
that most people don't know about but it
was super helpful we also actually have
an editor built into Google cloud if
you've never used that check that out
but if you're already on github already
on bitbucket
whatever you can also use a bunch of
other
I think that's fine you can just say hey
any time I commit to github hook this in
run this code so in this case I've been
you know working on whatever service
this is it's clearly a very good commit
log I'm a very good developer and
imagine that last commit I made a
mistake right
I have accidentally broken something
it's failing in production somehow it
got past my tests somehow we got in this
situation so a deployment looks like
this and if it goes it goes past those
tests and it succeeds we'll see all the
logs we'll see information about what
container it built we'll see all that
nice output of what this build resulted
in and in this case the artifact of this
build is a container but it doesn't have
to be you can just use it to deploy
things or whatever you want it
absolutely does not have to be a
container but like I said if I've made a
mistake and I have committed something
wrong or anyone on our team has
committed something wrong and
accidentally gotten something into
production it's pretty easy to rollback
right in a traditional situation you
pull down the git repo right you
remember how to roll back the latest
config which I have no I or the latest
commit which I have no idea how to do
you would have to I would have to google
that and be like all right something
something had hard reset something and
about after probably like 10 minutes of
messing around I'd be able to figure out
how to go back a commit and then I'd be
able to like go rerun the scripts and
get into production but if you have a
nice tool like this all of these builds
are really nice and contained so again
hard to see but there's a very tiny
button up at the top that just says
rebuild and if I hit that rebuild button
it's gonna go it's gonna go to the
commit that this build was built on
rerun everything redo all the steps and
at the end of the day throw with that
build back up and by the end of the day
I mean you know after like 30 seconds
once it's done building so now instead
of panicking and looking up get logs and
remembering how to do this we can just
say okay just roll back just hit that
button and we are now back that commit
and we turn a few minutes of downtime
you know
what could have been half-hour more
people trying to remember how to do
things looking up obscure documentation
things like that so it's really really
helpful I think one of the things that
CI CD tools are most valuable for it's
not just deploying to production because
that's great but if we want people to
always be testing their code and always
experimenting and thing like that we
really want to have different
environments and this this leads into
the next topic here where you have
configs and environmental code so if I
config I mean things like API keys
servers anything that your your service
is actually talking to these are all
configuration values right any any port
anything like that and then we have
environments which are kind of groups of
configuration information so if you have
a service that's talking to a MySQL
database for example and you know that
when you deploy that service to staging
and you have to tell it to talk to a
different my sequel database you have to
run it with the right config file you
have to deploy it to staging with the
right config file use otherwise what's
going to happen is it's going to talk to
the production database and very bad
things are gonna happen are they gonna
leak PII or you're gonna accidentally
delete something you didn't mean to
delete or anything like that and this is
why we add into this idea and this is
this is a very firebase the idea the
firebase knows where your project is
running at any time any code you're
writing with firebase has an idea of
what project it's associated with so
this is true in our client-side SDKs so
if you're running in the Android SDK you
can get that project ID out and you can
say all right what project ID is my base
configuration for if you're writing a
cloud function we have environmental
configuration values they're basically
environment variables but made a little
nicer and these know exactly what
environment you're in so if I was
building a service and I was working up
these configuration values and saying oh
here's my users database and here's my
whatever whatever database if I
committed that into get not only do I
now have a log of potentially sensitive
information there could be credentials
in there or anything
like that but we're also into a
situation where it's up to the developer
again think of the new developer think
of someone who doesn't have that much
experience here it's up to them to know
to switch those with the right
credentials when they deploy into
staging so another mantra get is for
code not configuration there are very
few situations where you should store
your configuration data in get it
generally doesn't work well because if
you leak a secret accidentally it's very
hard to undo and if you have a situation
where these variables are limited in
scope you're now dealing with like
specific permissions to a repo and like
only this person should be able to read
and this person can change them it's
much much easier to keep all of that
configuration data in the environment so
let me give you two examples of what
that looks like here is a web page very
simple web page pulling in environmental
data from firebase so if you're if
you've ever deployed a web app on
firebase hosting this is the gist of
what you can do and it looks basically
the same we're pulling in the to
firebase SDK age we're ready to use the
firebase SDK that's great but we have
that bottom line there that I'm just
going to score firebase flush and enjoy
yes and what that's doing is saying hey
initialize my firebase app on my
JavaScript 2.2 whatever project I'm
currently running on so if you are
deploying this locally it'll be whatever
your local project is set to use if
you're deploying this to production
it'll automatically pull it from the
environment so this means you can now
commit this without any configuration
information you come in to get and then
when you go to deploy it it will
automatically connect to where you
deploy it so now if we're talking about
a staging environment and a production
environment or a development environment
or whatever we're not concerned about
this out we need to play the exact same
code no changes and it'll be safe diving
into this a little more here's another
cloud function it's a more lovely Java
Script that I don't recommend using and
you can see here we you know do some
simple on write for you know check an
email send some sense of service to that
but we have this authorization token
down there if you're not familiar with
that syntax that's just string
interpolation in modern JavaScript the
important part is functions dot config
dot some service sake
the key stored in our environment that
isn't checked into our code it's not
written down anywhere except in Google
Cloud where it's nice and safe so when
you go to call this service there's no
chance you're gonna call the production
credentials this the thing I always
think about here is stripe if you're
ever doing striped payment processing
the likelihood that you will use your
test key in your production environment
or vice versa is very high so doing this
allows you to really easily separate
that and just be like my code is my code
my configuration it's in the environment
and I have my two or three projects set
up that are the ones we deploy to and
test with and unless we allow someone to
accidentally deploy to production
there's no way they're accidentally
charging on stripe or doing something
like that so yeah if your code has no
configuration and no idea about the
environment it has no context of what
project to associate with it has no idea
what's going on except from what the
environment tells us you write these
really nice clean like independent
bundles of code it's a much easier much
more like atomic bundle that you can
then take and deploy to different places
and ship around it's extremely extremely
clean but this isn't everything right
we've been talking a lot about writing
code and we don't have that much time so
luckily we're getting into the last few
sections that once your code is in the
real world you want to keep an eye on it
and anytime we're talking about keeping
an eye on anything in Google cloud we're
talking about stackdriver you probably
use fact driver or heard of it it's an
incredibly powerful tool for just all
sorts of analysis of your code and your
performance and all of these great
things that has all these metrics that
Google services firebase is no exception
two rows off to it if you ever wanted
for example more insight in your
firebase database or your cloud
firestore instance that information is
all in stackdriver you just got to go
like a look at it but stackdriver
like anything has a barrier to entry
right and I think one of the biggest
themes of this talk is that we want to
make things easy on developers we want
to make them do as little as possible in
a way that helps us build more
confidently and so developers already
used to this idea the system of how we
debug code and I would love to tell you
that I believe the fundamental idea of
debugging code is like breakpoints and
good tooling but it's not
people cancel out log or printf the hell
out of their code doesn't matter who you
are it's how we debug stuff and that's
fine
right like it's great that we have more
advanced tools in Google cloud and in
stackdriver that do crazy introduction
breakpoints and stocks and stuff like
that
but most developers aren't going to use
those and they're especially not going
to use them if they're trying to ship
something by next week so let's just
make it better right let's not change
anything that the developer is already
doing let's just make the situation
better for them so just by console
logging and a cloud function if you
normally go to the firebase console and
check it out you see a fairly simple
view of this information but if you head
over to stock driver logging inside the
cloud console you will see a much nicer
view of that same data so this is every
log it actually pulls logs from all
sorts of Google cloud services it's not
just a firebase it's not just cloud
functions you can get logs from
kubernetes or a cloud run or anything
like that but in this case these are
just console logs from our functions and
you can see it's broken up into a few
columns here left column a little
colored icon to tell us what type of log
it is and after that we have what time
it was happened at but next to that we
have the function name that reported
this log so we have two functions here
request cool and fulfill cool and then
after that we have a unique invocation
ID that one-to-one whatever whatever
that's the ID of that invocation and
then after that we have whatever printed
so this is great but it's better if we
can filter in so if we click on one of
those nice numbers it'll automatically
write this with a query for us and say
all right here's the log for the
invocation of that function that's
specific one that you just clicked on
and we can see the entire lifecycle and
you can see now when it's not in this
entirely big you know blob of logs that
we have things like how long the
function took we have an idea about what
went through and what happened and this
is without changing console.log this is
just still console logging but getting
ingested into stock driver logging
automatically and this is already there
for all your cloud functions are already
using you just have to go click on it so
this is great you can write all sorts of
custom queries you can do all sorts of
different things
in terms of creating custom metrics if
you wanted alerts based on when certain
airs happen if you wanted you to search
for the word error and so anytime that
happens we should alert someone you can
do that but luckily you don't have to
because we can do even better so we want
to give developers the tools to debug
without placing a burden on them and one
of those burdens is not just changing
the code but the other burden is
actually like looking at these logs and
understanding them right like looking
through this is not trivial that takes
time so why don't we give them a nice
aggregate view of that of that data of
those logs and let's do it without any
code changes well that's stackdriver
error reporting
it's your error reporting again it's
just in there you just got to go like
click the button please use stackdriver
error reporting and all your cloud
functions all your firebase stuff will
get aggregated in to these so instead of
a big big log I have a few instances of
errors that have happened in my code and
we have a lot of nice information here
like how many times it's happened when
it was most recently seen we get of
course if we click into that the full
stack trace we get a histogram of when
it's been happening we can link it to
internal bug tracking we have all of
this and most importantly we have the
ability to set up alerts when new bugs
occur so we don't have to ever look at
that log reactively we don't have to go
think about it we can just say all right
if a new error occurs or an old there
happens again just shoot me an email
hit it up hit up paid your duty right
it's Kali on call do whatever you have
to do in order to get this information
it cost that something is going on and
again no code changes so once we've done
that right once we are very aware of all
the new errors happening the realization
we all have is that really not
everything bad happening is an error
right like there are situations you
don't want to get into that aren't
errors but they're not good so what do
we do how do we have that insight well
stackdriver has another thing and this
section of stackdriver is where all of
these metrics from all these Google
services get poured into this one place
and in this case we're looking it's very
hard to see but we're looking at the
execution of two different cloud funds
there's a pink line on the bottom and a
blue line on the top the blue line is
the front-end server and the pink line
is the one that actually does the
creation of the content that gets served
up so you would expect in all situations
that that blue line be bigger than that
pink line because at most the amount of
requests to create something can be as
big as the amount of requests to serve
it so in this case where that pink line
is like super low that's exactly what
we'd expect and we can go in here we can
look at all sorts of metrics we can look
at CPU time and memory use and aggregate
data over years or days or hours we can
create dashboards all from all this
firebase information and it's not just
stopped at cloud functions like I said
we have databases we have cloud storage
we have the most insight available to
you about firebase all thrown into
stackdriver metrics so that's cool but
again it's not the same if we don't get
if I have to look at that thing and
think about it that's not as good so we
can go in create custom alerts for
example in this situation I have a cloud
function that runs once a day goes clear
some caches you know did some other
housekeeping I don't really care if that
function doesn't run on any given day
but I do want to know if it stopped
running so I set up this alert based on
a custom report in stock driver logging
that says hey if this function hasn't
been invoked in about 48 hours go ahead
hit me up shoot me a message and let me
know if something's going wrong this can
tie into pager duty or any of the other
on-call services so that you can know
when something whatever it is is going
wrong in your service and of course
because these situations are you know
nice well understood alerts and
conditions if that situation gets
resolved you'll get told about that too
so not only do you get told hey that
function didn't run for some reason but
you'll get told oh no it did now you're
all good
all right last section shortest section
pricing pricing calculators are great
but they're absolutely useless if you
have no information if you've ever sat
down and thought man I want to build
this thing we're gonna do this thing how
much would it cost to run a hundred you
know a hundred users on this service or
a thousand or a hundred thousand that's
just about impossible to tell you have
no idea how many mega hurt hours you're
gonna use you probably can't guess how
much
you need any of these things are very
very difficult to tell
so if only there was a way some service
that gave us incredibly detailed
information about our service so that we
could put reasonable numbers into these
into these calculators and we just
talked about that a stackdriver all that
information to do forward-looking in for
analysis
it's available in stackdriver and you
can plop it into your calculator
second thing firebase now has paid
support so all of this everything I've
talked to about you can get on the phone
now and talk to someone if you are
already a GCP paid support member you we
now have experts staffed there to talk
to you about firebase answer technical
questions anything about scaling
firebase you need to know is now
included in GCP paid support all right
so what did we cover code testing
deployment rollback environment
monitoring pricing that's pretty much
what you need to be thinking about I
appreciate you all coming to the talk
I'll be around for questions thank you
for coming
[Music]
you